what's going on guys so I got some big
news for you that you are going to be
very pleased about if you're on my blog
TV show last night you would have heard
this news in advance I'm sure you guys
have heard of schmoes know they are my
favorite film critics on YouTube and
they have invited me to collaborate with
them on their website a lot of people
don't actually know they have a website
but not just you to reviewers they have
an entire website that has blogs about
movies written by all different types of
writers links to their podcasts
information about things they do their
reviews all different types of stuff and
they actually messaged me and invited me
to write for the website every single
Monday so I hope that you guys look
forward to movie monday with Stuckmann
yes that is what my new column is going
to be called really excited to start
writing for them my first blog is going
to be out this Monday and I'll give you
a hint it's about so please definitely
go check out their website schmoes know
com have the link right there in the
description for you and please read my
blogs I'm going to be doing every single
Monday I'll cover entertainment news
casting news things like that another
thing I'm going to be doing is something
that you guys have consistently asked me
about you always kind of ask me know
what movies do i watch at home so from
time to time I'll briefly discuss movies
i see at home and you guys can know
about my opinions on those two old new
whatever so once again go to schmoes
know comm check out their website
definitely continue to watch the website
there's a lot of cool stuff on there
every single Monday movie monday was
stuck hopefully you'll enjoy it and
thank you for watching